[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh Gutfeld Greg let's welcome tonight's
guest
she does crack her Knuckles at work host
of Kennedy on Fox Business and Kennedy
Saves the World podcast Kennedy
thank you
he's wider than the powder in Greg's
Green Room Fox News contributor Tom
shallou
[Applause]
on weekends she goes out clubbing seals
it's awful
no no
we'll try it again that's a gun in her
pocket and she's glad to see you host of
luxury hunting Lodges of America on Fox
Nation Katie Pavlik
foreign
can be used as Chopsticks Fox News
contributor cat Tim
now that I have no friends left on this
panel
okay before we get to some stories it's
Friday so it's time for this
Greg's leftovers
and that's not the first time I've taken
Greg's food out of the refrigerator so
it's all good
yeah it's leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week now here
are the rules just like how Greg does it
this will be my first time reading these
here we go
on Tuesday President Biden traveled to
the U.S Virgin Islands to enjoy some
holiday downtime
which caused millions of Americans to
ask downtime from what
we're off to a good start
not surprisingly after three days in the
hot sun Joe's new best friend is a
volleyball named Wilson
[Applause]
all right
according to a new study women outscored
men on empathy tests in countries all
over the world
that's only because women did the math
said your sexist uncle
is that no all right this week Southwest
canceled thousands of flights creating a
log Jam of unclaimed luggage and as a
precaution the airline says they've
hired dozens of new employees to help
control Sam Britain
[Applause]
that was good
because he steals luggage that's awesome
all right
after terminating their deal with Kanye
West Wait no that's Yi or yay
Adidas now has a half a billion dollars
of unsold shoes
but the company plans on giving the
sneakers to their Factory workers once
they're big enough to wear them
[Applause]
that's when you laugh and you really try
not to
this week comedian Bill Cosby
he's a comedian Bill Cosby announced
that he's making plans to begin touring
again in 2023
say the official tagline for the tour
will be you'll laugh until you're
completely unconscious
foreign
a woman was arrested this week in South
Carolina after attacking her husband
when she found dirty photos on his phone
but at his defense he did tell his wife
that he received a lot of junk mail
I get it yeah that's why he got beat up
you gotta you gotta have a better punch
line you get caught
blame it on your kids
I would never do that all right
James Cameron announced that he edited
the Avatar sequel to remove scenes of
glorifying gun violence he says he
didn't want to give the idea that the
most dangerous group is ex-wives
he married her
oh is there a Sam bankman freed is
getting tips for survival if he ends up
in prison
although if he does get assaulted one
thing's for sure it won't happen in the
weight room
hahaha
because that's how Dahmer got killed all
right all right
a recent survey found that half of
Americans enjoy spending alone time
hiding in their bathrooms sometimes for
hours
and for 20 bucks probably kill meat will
hide in your bathroom
[Laughter]
why why do we such a nice guy
a computer programmer is giving people
the chance to see the effects of an
asteroid hitting their City using a new
web app
or as they call it in Detroit a window
[Laughter]
why would you have to
[Music]
this week South Korea formerly lifted a
ban on imported sex dolls
although they did keep the ban on dolls
from Iraq since they can blow themselves
up
[Applause]
there's more
a recent interview former First Lady
Michelle Obama said she couldn't stand
her husband Barack for 10 years of their
marriage
oh yeah try 40 said Hillary Clinton
[Applause]
okay and now some real news
wasn't that news
he put Pinocchio to shame with his Lying
Game I'm not okay I'm not doing the
rhymes
the more people inquire the more that
his pants are on
flames
not rhyming I speak of New York Republic
Congress in elect George Santos
soon we'll find out how act well soon
we'll find out he's actually a young
blonde girl from Switzerland
I believe he's I believe he's Kaiser
Soze at this point cat that's a movie I
know you didn't see it but the bad guy
tricked everybody okay
she doesn't watch movies
he told lies about his work history
education religion and come to find out
he even lied about his own mother's
death
who would lie about one's loved one's
death
Santos if that's his real name
originally said his mom died in 9 11 but
she actually passed away 15 years later
from cancer
he hasn't even been sworn in yet and
there are already calls for him to
resign as well as calls warning him that
his car warranty is about to expire
but so far Santos is holding firm even a
federal prosecutor in New York is
launching an investigation the probe is
in its earliest stages but if it if it
goes deep enough it could uncover even
more Fabrications
which with each layer it gets more and
more disturbing like uh Greg's Magic
Mike audition tape
shame he didn't get that part
meanwhile Democratic Congressman Richie
Torres is launching the cleverly named
Santos act to punish other candidates
for lying about their background
Santos act stands for stop another
non-truthful office Seeker
boy that was clever
but that could backfire on government
officials like these
[Applause]
and this person
[Applause]
I have never done that that's the truth
we have the photo
chat we've all probably fluffed a resume
every now and then but I mean is this
just to lie about your mom's death yeah
it wasn't even like there was a grain of
Truth like not only did she not die in
the 9 11 attacks she didn't die like on
9 11 2016 either
it was in December and he tweeted about
that himself like it wasn't like people
had to go digging they just looked for
the stuff that he'd said before I I
don't understand
also how it took so long for all this to
happen I don't I don't understand who
does this all politicians lie this I
wonder if he's ever said anything true
well I guess we'd have to ask have we
found the true thing no you know Kennedy
I made the point in the joke where I
showed all the politicians is this
really that shocking no I mean because
literally what politician Republican
Democrat independent that is not pretty
much based offline no Elizabeth Warren
not only has her political career but
also her academic career based on a lie
about a fake Heritage so yes there is
Stolen Valor all over the place that's
all politicians do you know Richard
Blumenthal the senator said that he was
in Vietnam no he kind of served in the
United States during Vietnam after his
five deferments but he was not in
Vietnam that is Stolen Valor uh this guy
is obviously a pathological liar I'm so
I I am so intrigued by his story and I
find it so comical that I think he's
going to a perfect place it's like he's
well suited for government when they go
back to Madagascar and and you know
Chris Rock the zebras running around
because he finally sees all the zebras
that's what George Santos gonna be like
he's like finally I'm in a chamber full
of other Liars this is amazing don't
compare life it was uh the thing that is
so brave about him is that he ascended
to office after killing Osama bin Laden
that's right he was there he was he he
wasn't the trigger man but he was the
guy behind him shoot now shoot now that
was the guy
Tom have you lied today I have not lied
today and uh but you know I don't care
about liars in Congress I mean they're
they're there that's what they do uh I
think he made some stupid lies though
because he was saying things like I went
to an elite University he's running as a
republican we don't like Elite
universities he should have said I went
to Community College would be like I
like that guy yeah she's gonna say it's
a welder yeah but and now this guy the
Democrat wants to pass a law
to say that if you lied and still got
elected we're going to hold you
accountable isn't that our job like if
we if we don't hold you accountable for
lying and we vote for you anyway it's on
us right and I think since we don't
really believe anybody and we got uh Mr
Fang Fang who's still sitting in his
congressional seat right yep uh well
who's that guy swalwell Eric swallow
shift I mean shift told lies about
actual political stuff he didn't Pat his
resume he told lies about people in
power and he held committee hearings and
he claimed he had evidence that he
didn't have and everybody yawned so if
you don't if you're gonna lie about the
big stuff and not get held accountable
this guy's just lying about his past
right well somebody else's past nobody
would be like oh his mom died of can
answer now I'm not voting for him yeah
like he already had a good story why I
mean President Joe Biden has repeatedly
said that his son died in Iraq he did
not die in Iraq he died from cancer many
years later so that is also Stolen Valor
there seems to be this double standard
about Democrats standing up and saying
this this horrible person who's lied
about everything in his career and
somehow got elected that he should
resign when all these other people in
their party get to stay it really is
just an indictment on politics and the
types of people who want to go to
Washington DC you know really good
people don't want to go to that town you
have to force them into going because it
really does suck but what about a law
against really bad opposition research
like isn't this the Democrats in New
York's fault for thinking that they had
that seat unlocked they didn't have to
campaign I mean how is it that the
opposition research team for the guy who
was running against him didn't find all
this stuff I mean a quick Google search
could have saved them the seat in New
York a Bing search could have done that
before we go come check out my live
shows I'll be in Jacksonville January
27th Knoxville February 1st Wayne New
Jersey on February 3rd plus many more
cities for tickets clinical click clink
click on my link tree or my Instagram to
my Instagram and Twitter pages the only
one Jacksonville is on Ticketmaster hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else